do
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening welcome to pierce morgan
uncensored the january the sixth
congressional hearings this week of
again divided america along predictable
partisan lines it was today a mob of
donald trump supporters stormed the u.s
capitol building in an attempt to
overturn his defeat to some the hearings
into what happened that day are
political theater a kangaroo court
banned on smearing president trump
before his likely third run to others
they've painted a devastating picture of
an irate man losing his mind and
entirely unfit to the office he held the
president said something to the effect
of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
well that account has already been
disputed by trump's supporters although
she said it under oath and their
reaction was not under oath what's
beyond dispute is that the hearings have
reignited debate about the man who still
favored to challenge her presidency
again in 2024 and ahead of the july 4th
weekend in the us we're revisiting one
of the most talked about interviews of
the year donald trump uncensored
the things i'm not happy about with the
presidency i'll be completely straight
with you to your face
one of them is what happened on january
6th which was a result of you refusing
to accept the result of the election
before you saw this
nancy pelosi is in charge of security
she didn't do her job she's half in
charge of it so the republicans the
mayor of death
the mayor of dc and nancy pelosi are in
charge actually republicans and the
democrats have 50 50. she was actually
cowering for terra in fear of her life
that day because there was a huge mob of
people if she were attacking the the
center of democracy in america i want to
read you what mitch mcconnell said he's
the senate minority well mitch mcconnell
is
not a good representative you can
respond to what he said but he still
remains party he remains he remains the
senior republican unfortunately okay but
he is right now we'll see what happens
okay fair enough
but he said this he's acknowledged that
joe biden was legitimate winner of the
2020 election he's rejected your claims
of fraud
and he said about january the sixth
we're all there we saw what happened it
was a violent insurrection for the
purpose of trying to prevent the
peaceful transfer of power after a
legitimately certified election from one
administration to the next that's what
it was he told mr the senate on february
the 13th last year former president
trump's actions preceding the riots were
a disgraceful dereliction of duty he
then said that word
there's no question that president trump
is practically and morally responsible
for provoking the events of that day and
even this he said about the rioters they
did this because they've been fed wild
falsehoods by the most powerful man on
earth because he was angry he'd lost an
election
number one
he knew nothing about what took place in
the election the press hates to write
about it but that election was rigged
and it was stolen you said to me 100 i
don't mean a little bit and you know
it's funny when a hillary clinton or
when
stacey abrams says oh the election was
rigged nobody says anything but when
trump says it but the difference is i
have proof
and we have
massive proof okay but let me know all
you have to do is take a look let me ask
you take a look at the ballot harvesting
that took place let me ask you this
you said to me once
that if you talk the talk and you're a
great talker i've seen that today if you
talk the talk you have to walk the walk
in the context of your claim about the
fortune election it's been 14 months
and
we've not seen this hard evidence of the
fraud that you say happen the press
won't report it the press
this is like a communist country worth
it's all over the place we have not
talked about everything let's just put
another thing to you i've watched this
whole debate rage and you've been
completely
unflagging in your refusal to accept
defeat you know why though you know why
because if our country doesn't have
fair and free elections and if our
country doesn't have borders we don't
have a country okay we have crooked
corrupt elections here's what i was
saying and i've proven it here's what i
would say to you i believe it was a free
and fair election and that you lost you
don't really believe that that's my
belief well then you're a fool however
then you're a fan maybe i am a fool i'd
be on the fool in in this conversation
and you're full and you haven't studied
okay i have studied it well maybe i am a
fool but of course i've studied it i've
read a lot about what happened with the
2020 election
and i see no hard evidence like i told
him that there was substantial voter
fraud nobody has seen that
but the bottom line with all this is
trump seems to me to be fighting on the
wrong hill about why he was treated
unfairly in 2020. there's another
argument that he could produce which i
think is a lot more merit just three
weeks before the election the new york
post published a sensational front page
story about hunter biden son of a now
president joe biden emails found on
hunter's abandoned laptop contained
proof that he sold influence while his
father was vice president
but the liberal-run social media giants
squashed the scandal with twitter and
facebook shamefully blocking the post
scoop they even stopped the post having
an account
a mainstream media dismissed it all as
russian disinformation so none of them
reported it properly and some believe
that if they had done it could have
swung the election in trump's favor in
other words if more people had known
about this story if more people had
scrutinized the story if it hadn't been
so wrongly censored that they might have
voted differently or stayed at home i
put this to president trump there is
another twist in this tale where i think
you're on much stronger ground and where
i would agree with you and that is the
suppression of the hunter biden laptop
scandal which is what it's become and it
could lead right to the top with joe
biden we don't know yet but it seems to
me that the way that mainstream media
and the tech giants conspired to
suppress that story literally removing
it from social media platform 17 not
reporting it not chasing it 50 senior
people coming out saying this was
russian disinformation all complete
nonsense
there is a belief that that could have
swung the election your way in other
words
when you talk about having a stolen
election actually you're on better
ground it seems to me with the hunter
are you ready i'm sorry they say it made
a 17-point difference but you know what
even without that
i want it and we want it big and we want
it easily it was so corrupt and
it was so corrupt in wisconsin
that they're saying what do we do they
don't know what to do they caught them
so
only a fool
and i guess you're a fool
only a fool would think that was a
legitimate you become a vote
i do now yeah frank sinatra said the
best revenge is massive success
isn't your best revenge rather than
talking constantly about the last i
don't talk constantly but you brought it
up i didn't you did you brought it up
excuse me you brought it up i didn't i
don't talk about it very much i do say
it was rigged mitch mcconnell
is
stupid
and he shouldn't have allowed it to
happen but he did
but if you look at the results and if
you look at what happened
but even you sitting here saying well
that doesn't matter but the law i think
the lawyers look i think the law is even
the numbers your own vice president mike
pence
says you lost the election mike was the
head of the republican party
because you lost it mike was foolish and
he was weak
it's an incredible thing to say about
mike pence someone who was probably the
most loyal vice president and most
supportive vice president in modern
american political history but no
because he doesn't think that election
was rigged or stolen he too gets thrown
under the bus
on sensor next trump and i fall out over
who's more honest
yeah i think i'm a very honest man much
more honest than you actually really
yeah i'm pretty honest because i don't
think you're real
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to piers morgan uncensored
in a moment donald trump's damning
verdict on british prime minister boris
johnson he tells me where he thinks
johnson's now getting it all wrong
and i asked him why boris intervened to
get my last interview with trump
cancelled two hours before it was due to
start
trump also has some scathing words for
the former german chancellor angela
merkel and tells me why he sent her a
white napkin of surrender
the first the question that seemingly
everybody in the world is desperate to
know the answer to will donald trump run
for president again
in 2024
so here's the big question for you
which everybody wants to know the latest
poll says if the 2024 election was held
tomorrow you would beat joe biden by six
points and kamala harris by 11 points in
other words you would be re-elected
president of the united states so are
you going to run again well you know for
reasons of campaign finance and
everything i'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this i think a lot of
people are going to be very happy
so you want me i i love our country our
country is going to hell i think a lot
of people are going to be very happy are
you going to run i'm not going to say
that but i think people are going to be
happy you might even be happy if it's
you against joe biden if you win the
republican nomination again and he runs
again
would you beat him
i believe right now anybody i think you
could beat them right now our country's
a mess our country has never been so
disrespected our borders have never been
so open we've never had in 44 years
inflation like we have it you run again
and you win which could well happen i
think whoever the republican candidate
right now it looks like the democrats
are going to get shellacked in the
midterms it's quite likely whoever is a
republican nominee
will end up being president it could be
you again
and for as many people who think that's
a great idea you'll know there are lots
of people who think that would be a
total nightmare far less
far less i think so yeah i think far
less i think people are very angry at
this country they're very angry at our
leadership
they wish they had their vote to do
again
we didn't need their vote because again
we won the election by a tremendous
margin we won the election actually very
easily
one of the other questions about
potentially running again is you've been
in that pressure cauldron of the white
house with your family they've all come
under huge attack
your children your wife melania
would you be happy to put them back in
there would they be happy to be back in
there well i won't get into that but i
will tell you they all love the country
and we did a great job and it's been a
tumultuous time for the world for the
country
there is a chance that you're going to
be running quite clearly you've made
that clear in this interview i don't
think i've made it clear i think that's
it but i think people are going to be
very happy i don't know there'll be
people unhappy but i think people are
going to be very happy so those who are
who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you i know you said recently that you
were very popular and i think you said
you'd be the most honest man in the
world last week i'm a very honest man
was that true
yeah i think i'm a very honest man
that's for those who don't like you much
more honest than you actually really
yeah i'm pretty honest because i don't
think you're real right yeah i think i'm
a much more honest person in most ways
and most recently why am i not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead
go ahead go ahead my question was this
what message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again
and will be distressed about it would
you come back with all the experience
you've had
of being president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently so i like this question
in a certain way because i came in and i
was attacked from day one
unfairly russia russia russia was a hoax
the impeachment hoax number one number
two it was all a big hoax the mueller
report
and i had to fight back and i had to
fight back strongly and if i didn't
fight back strongly i wouldn't have
survived and i say it and i say it loud
i had two jobs to do
run the country really well and the
second was to survive
no other president went through this
fake stuff i only ask you when we did
celebrity apprentice together
which i've really enjoyed and it's good
yeah yeah yeah when i did that with you
i saw a very different donald trump in
the boardrooms for those hours every
night
you were you know you weren't as
aggressive and confrontational except i
wasn't under siege with phony with phony
russian russia
by the way
the russian collusion thing was
ridiculous no no and many others right
but my point is if you got a chance
again would we see more of that donald
trump do you think
depends on how you're greeted
but if you greet it unfairly you have to
be tough and you have to fight
i would like that i would much prefer
that but it depends on how you agreed it
but i would do
when i say this our country's in trouble
something has to happen and if it
doesn't happen and if we don't have
smart leadership you're going to end up
with no world the world is going to be
blown to pieces we have stupid people
now running our country the world is
going to be blown to pieces
what about britain under the leadership
of boris johnson and why did johnson
cancel my interview with trump a few
days before his 2019 uk election
there's some interesting answers but
first trump's utterly withering verdict
on former german chancellor angela
merkel they never got on well and
perhaps you can now understand why
you were very critical of angela merkel
in germany for being so energy dependent
on russia you've been completely
vindicated that's true about angela
merkel in fact her reputation is getting
shattered with every day this conflict
goes it should be shattered she should
have never done it i had it out with her
i sent her the white flag of surrender i
sent her a white flag it was in the form
of a law
oh yeah
i had it brought right over to her at a
different table i said it's the white
flag of surrender
she said but what do you mean i said you
are dependent on russia
for energy
you you must be kidding
i mean just look at the history of
germany and russia
when it happens you might as well just
do me a favor
lift this flag of surrender you know
what it was it was a very luxurious
napkin
okay
where was that and i sent it what did
you do at one of the meetings one of our
many meetings we had with uh you know
between the g7 the g20 you have all the
different g's
and but i said i said
you're going to be
someday in a problem with russia
and you are going to have no choice but
to surrender
because new german leader has done a
complete u-turn he recognized that what
you were saying then was completely
correct but who wouldn't recognize i
also think that when she took in
millions of people
she hurt germany very badly millions of
people flowed through europe and flowed
into a country she heard instead of
resettling them someplace and spending
money but settling in their area where
they would rather be anyway the war
forced them out
bush got us into that mess in the middle
east bush has done a tremendous
disservice people forget we were
supposed to meet in december 2019 just
before the pandemic in london
and at the last minute you cancelled my
interview
because of an intervention from the
british prime minister i believe
well that's true i mean you knew that
and uh i was over there as his guest
so if he asks me not to do that i have
to do that we have why didn't he want
you to talk to me i don't know i didn't
even ask him the election the uk
election was a few days later yeah i was
told it was because he was worried that
between us we might create something
that made cost in the election well i
like him and uh i've always liked him i
think he's getting a little bit liberal
he's getting a little bit green what is
life like
as an ex-president
well it's uh
interesting it's beautiful it's complex
sometimes
we have a lot of endorsements going out
and have gone out we've done very well
on endorsing candidates that i think are
very good
and they are very good and we've taken
people from
who we're not going to win and now
they're winning big you're talking like
somebody who
feels he has unfinished business
well
we did a
really good job we created
an economy that was incredible and now
supply chain problems inflation problems
gasoline selling for five six seven
dollars
think of it a gallon when i left it was
under two dollars
and it was largely under two dollars for
a long period of time 187
167 at one point
and now it's five six seven eight
dollars depending on where you are going
up much higher
uh and we have a war that would have
never happened if i was president that
war would have never happened
when the invasion started you were quite
praiseworthy of vladimir putin you said
he was a genius this was a sabby move
he was going in as a peacemaker no no
that's the fake news's version no tell
me the truth when he built up soldiers
on the border i said that's very smart
brilliant move
because i thought he was negotiating
when he went in i said no longer a
brilliant move when you see the scenes
mr president
of maternity hospitals i think it's
terrible when you see refugees being
attacked as they flee grandmothers
children babies
you see the decimation of previously
prosperous cities living in a thriving
new democracy when you watch what's
happening i mean do you agree with my
assessment that vladimir putin is now an
evil genocidal monster yeah but i also
do when i look at i do oh sure
who wouldn't what's happening is
horrible
when you see rockets going into
apartment buildings and there are plenty
of people in those buildings you know
they think they're like the people who
moved out they didn't move they want to
stay because they think they're safe in
their apartments far more people are
dead than you think when i see all the
death and all that destruction
and it's such a stupid war because you
had a country it was working that was
had problems lots of problems but
other countries have problems too
it was such a horrible
waste to be doing it
you see swings outside you see
playgrounds you see hospitals it was a
country
and
the people were happy i guess a lot of
them were happy because they're
certainly fighting for it but i'll tell
you what i really think i said isn't it
a shame all those people are dead all
because of a rigged election because if
our election wasn't rigged you would
have had nobody dead when you said to
putin don't invade ukraine yeah what was
his well i told him what our response
was going to be and his response was
really i said really what did you say
your response and you know what if he
believed me good but if he believed me
only five percent he would have said
i'll never do it well did you say the
response i'm not going to say that i'm
not going to say that but it was a very
strong response did you threaten for
example the nuclear capability i don't
want to talk about that
i don't want to talk about that what i
did say is
we're going to be
very strongly responding if you do
that i also said to president xi don't
go into taiwan
and there's going to be a very strong
response they both understood that they
both had the same reaction really
really
i said really
the thing that may keep him out of
taiwan is how poorly russia is doing and
how vicious it has to be how horrible it
has to be because china sees that and
nobody wants to see what's happening
so what would you do right now in
ukraine if you were the president putin
uses the n word i call it the n word he
uses the n word the nuclear word all the
time that's a no-no you're not supposed
to do that he uses it on a daily basis
and everybody's so afraid so afraid so
afraid and as they're afraid he uses it
more and more that's why he's doing the
kind of things he's doing
he's doing them because he thinks
nobody's gonna ever attack us because
they're all stupid and they're afraid to
talk i totally agree with you okay so
what would you do instead of excuse me
it's
a little complicated
instead of
you know cow towing instead of
biden saying oh
he's got nuclear weapons he keeps saying
he's got new
we have better
weapons that we have the greatest
submarine power in history what would
you say and do i would say we have far
more than you do far
far more powerful than you and you can't
use that word ever again you cannot use
the nuclear word ever again and if you
do
we're going to have problems
my reading of what you've been saying is
that when you were talking to putin when
you were president and he was talking
about potentially invading ukraine that
you threatened him with your nuclear
capability i threatened him like he has
never been threatened before did you
threaten to use nuclear weapons i don't
want to say that i threatened him like
he has never been threatened before
what's your message for putin now right
now
if you could talk to him what would you
say to him
i would say it's a shame what you've
done
you're killing protect i think
potentially look you know if these
people aren't smart
and they're not
our leaders are not smart
if they're not smart you're gonna end up
in a nuclear war
this is just the beginning this is the
beginning and i've been the best
predictor of things ever now it doesn't
have to happen it shouldn't happen but
if our people aren't smart you can end
up in a nuclear war what's your message
i think they're dealing he's watching
this interview and he will be look what
would you say i think they're
dealing with them incorrectly i think
what they're saying
it's almost like they're speaking with
fear and they don't understand we have
one weapon alone that would destroy
everything should putin get out of
ukraine right now they should make a
deal and they can make a deal and they
should do it fast when people look back
on this period of time
we're going to be ashamed at what we've
done
or what we haven't done to stop this
catastrophe this is a catastrophe
this is in a way already a world war has
russia made itself with this invasion
has it made itself an enemy of the
united states well i think two things
have happened number one they've proven
to be less powerful than we thought
that's a good thing from our standpoint
but at the same time they have a second
degree of weapon
that is very powerful
and
nobody can be allowed to use it talk
about it or threaten with it we have
more powerful than them
and there would be no russia there would
be no russia but we don't want to talk
about that but when i watch biden say oh
he's got nuclear weapons we can't do
this
you can't do that you know i confronted
kim jong-un
and all of a sudden i got a call they'd
like to meet
it was like what do you think you're fun
to do
what did you say to him well verbally i
confronted him you know that
he said i have a red button on my desk
meaning a nuclear button i said i have a
red button on my desk too but it's
bigger and stronger than yours and mine
works
and they said well nobody's ever talked
to us that way i took a lot of a lot of
heat when i said that when you look back
on the the four years you were president
of the united states it was very
polarizing in many ways you know that
what do you think was your biggest
success
so when you say polarizing i think it's
more polarized now than it ever i don't
disagree i don't disagree joe biden said
he would unify the country there's
certainly no sign of that happening so i
don't disagree with you but your tenure
four years
give me the one thing that you're
proudest of i can't say one because
there are too many things but i'll give
you one that's a lot of people don't
talk about but then they say wow that's
true we started no wars
we didn't have russia fighting in
ukraine we didn't have china threatening
every day
taiwan they wouldn't have done it and
russia would have never go into they
would have never gone into ukraine never
no chance how can you be sure about i
know it i know my people and i know
putin and he would have never done it i
think the the afghanistan withdrawal was
so incompetent
with the 85 billion and the dead
soldiers but to be clear you wanted
withdrawal you wanted us forces out of
afghanistan i'm the one that started it
right i took it down your complaint is
about the execution of the withdrawal
what's the actual decision to withdraw
withdraw with strength and with dignity
but i was the one that got it down to
two thousand soldiers how would you have
done it if you'd still be in president
number one very simple i would have left
the military to last not you don't take
out the military first we took out our
military first
a child would say you can't do that we
took the military out
and then we had thousands of people that
were american people some of whom are
still there a large number are still
there bigger than people think
uh i have never seen anything so
incompetent and in my opinion by the way
not only the soldiers that were killed
we have horribly horribly wounded
soldiers
and leaving 85
billion dollars of the best equipment in
the world best military equipment
leaving millions of afghan women
in the hands of taliban correct who have
immediately taken them back to the dark
age correctly that's by trashing their
education trashing their women's rights
i mean that's an abrogation of a moral
duty isn't it yeah it sure is
do you think that it fueled vladimir
putin's
ambitions with the ukraine invasion
seeing what appeared to be
america in surrender mode yes i think
that was the reason i think that's why
he did it when they saw the way we acted
in afghanistan the way we ran like
surrendered and again you have to
understand i had a
very strong very powerful relationship
powerful in the sense that they
respected our country and me
there was no games with the taliban and
its leader who's still their leader by
the way
and they would have never done this
agree we ran away he said hey
this is no longer trump i'm going to go
and take you let me let me and then it
worked out to be not so good
so the president and i didn't agree
about everything as you just seen but
there were some things we did agree
about including the duke and duchess of
netflix and mr trump didn't pull his
punches when it came to the dynamics of
harry and megan's relationship
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
trump and i didn't always see eye to eye
on everything in our interview but one
thing we did agree about was the royal
family the former president didn't hold
back calling harry whipped lavishing
praise on the queen and giving his
thoughts on the future of the monarchy
and the prince andrew scandal but first
i started by asking about that historic
state visit you know i met the queen
yeah it was supposed to be for 20
minutes i saw you just after you saw it
right it was supposed to be just a quick
meeting
and it was beautiful the pompad ceremony
nobody does it like the english i don't
know what it is but nobody does it like
we have a certain dinner but i met her
and it turned out to be more than an
hour substantially because she liked me
and i liked her and she's let it be
known she liked me and i let it be
honest i've had other members of the
royal family tell me they enjoyed your
company we had a great time and then
they honored the united states but they
honored me that night which is really
the honor of the country and it was at
the top level and i sat next to her we
talked the whole night
and somebody said
we've never seen her smile so much we
had a great time she was laughing and
smiling they said they've never seen her
have such a good time at a state dinner
you know normally they're a little
boring okay this wasn't boring so
i have a lot of respect for the queen
she's incredible she loves her country i
think she's incredible look at her she's
been queen for what 70 years or
something and
she's never made a mistake even when the
guy broke into a room
sits him down talks to him quietly does
what everything she's done now some of
the kids it's you know they make a
little mistake every once in a while
sometimes a big one what did you make of
this the prince andrew's going for well
it was a terrible thing it was a you
know terrible thing i think terrible for
a lot of people but but
the queen i don't know has she ever even
made a mistake
she's an incredible woman i'm not a fan
of megan yeah i'm not a fan and i wasn't
right from the beginning what did you
make and i think
i think poor harry is being led around
by his nose
and i think he's an embarrassment you
know here's my issue with it i think
that
they've quit the country they've quit
royal duty they're living in luxury in
california
they want to use their royal titles to
exploit them for massive financial gain
without any of the duty that comes with
the royal titles i don't think you can
have your royal cake and eat it that's
my argument about it so i want to know
what's going to happen when harry
decides he's had enough of being bossed
around or maybe when she decides that
she likes some other guy better i want
to know what's going to happen
when it ends
okay do you think it's going gonna win i
do i've been a very good predictor as
you know i predicted almost everything
it'll end and it'll end bad and i wonder
if harry's gonna go back on his hands
and knees back into
uh the beautiful city of london and say
please you know i think harry has been
led down a path i found it when i heard
he wasn't going to prince phillips
memorial terrible
i found that i couldn't believe that
yeah
he would not go to that he was at the
super bowl he was a texas rodeo but he
couldn't find time to go on a plane i
think it was it was a terrible thing
many terrible things that might have
been
as you mentioned it that might have been
the worst of all
because he was you know like her he was
a tough cookie too i remember years ago
prince philip came to
new york and we were in the plaza hotel
and there were many people wanting to
meet him
and we were all taking a picture with
him many people and the photographers
say i'll never forget this he was tough
the photographer said please move back
there were like 30 of us and he said no
you moved back
and that was simple i said that's pretty
good you know this guy's tough but i'll
never forget that i don't mean that in a
derogatory i mean it was directed
yeah instead of having this whole group
of people moving back plenty of room the
photographer and he immediately moved
back i said wow
i mean
the queen had to be pretty tough because
i think she was he was tough when he
died i think it was a devastating moment
for the queen i think they had a great
relationship but he was a strong guy i
never forgot a little moment right he
just said no you moved back
and he didn't say it in a nice way
because the photographer was pushing
everybody around a little bit foolishly
but um
i thought it was terrible when he didn't
go to the funeral of prince philip yeah
i think i think the harry
situation has
is going to unfold in a much different
way if you were the queen is it at the
stage now would you remove their royal
title i would i take
the only thing i disagree with the queen
on probably one of the only things ever
is that i think she should have said if
that's your choice fine
but you no longer have titles you no
longer and frankly
don't come around
you just because her loyalty is to the
country she said that many times her
loyalty is to the country
and i think that he has been so
disrespectful to the country
and it's a great country
i own a lot of things there i own a
place called turnberg and in aberdeen i
own and i mean we have aberdeen is
beautiful the oil capital of europe and
i own things there and i love that
country it's it's incredible it's
scotland i love i love turnberry i love
what i did there i built things here
and i respect great one of the best in
the world and i will tell you um
she is she is more passionate about
her role and and the country it's going
to be very interesting
someday she won't be there right it'll
be very interesting what happens and i
know charles pretty well
and i think camilla i think you sat with
her i do and and i'll tell you what uh
she was on my right the queen was on my
left and i said
queen
i really have to talk to camilla for a
little while too you know
no we we couldn't break apart and i
talked to camilla and camilla was so
nice
you know different than i thought she
was funny she was smart quick
i really liked she was great i like her
too and uh i like charles i mean he's
serious do you think they'll make a good
king and queen when that time comes i
hope so i think it's it's a it's going
to be tricky
he's going to have to be
you know it's going to be tricky because
they are truly replacing you talking
about a legendary this woman
she's got to have the all-time record of
the greatest i mean in your lifetime is
she the greatest of all the leaders of
any kind well so my mother was born in
scotland and i remember as a little
boy anything where the queen was on
anything at all where
and it was the pomp and ceremony but my
mother had tremendous
love and respect
for the young queen at that time he
would have been a kid when she got
coronated right i was mid-50s but but my
mother wouldn't leave the screen
and she'd go back to scotland almost
every year you know she loved scotland
she loved but she loved the queen
and
so does everybody and for this person to
come along and criticize the queen
it's just
you just can't do that so it'll be
interesting to see how it all works out
harry is whipped do you know the
expression i'm familiar with i won't use
the full expression but harry is whipped
like no person i think i've ever seen
the most weak man in the world this is i
don't know that's going to be a big one
but he is he is a whipped man yeah
there's been much speculation about
whether donald trump stomped off out of
our interview i plan to resolve that
tonight and show you exactly what
happened before all this do you remember
the most talked about tv walkout before
because that involved me
has she said anything about you since
she cut you off i don't think she has
but yet you continue to trash her okay
i'm done with this no no no no sorry no
actually do you know what that's
possible
maybe not mine no no no no no no no no
no no no no i'm being
sorry
absolutely diabolical behavior it
certainly was by him but shortly after
that i lost my job for having an opinion
and president trump it turned out
watched it all go down
let's talk about censorship my show is
called piers morgan uncensored okay you
like the title i like it yeah very much
i know you very well you blame me for
you it's a good title i don't think you
can avoid it no so it's an accurate
title i don't think if they told you
to behave yourself you can't so it's
probably a very accurate title i chose
the title because i lost my last job
the good morning britain show i thought
you overreacted by the way well i'll
tell you what happened i mean the guy
the guy was a stiff and it wasn't about
he didn't have to do it wasn't actually
about the walk out so you made it about
him he got he got probably going to get
you you're right about it but here's
what
happened so i watched the oprah winfrey
interview with meghan markle and prince
harry and i'm angry watching it i think
and you were right to be i thought the
attacks on the royal family were
disgraceful i agree and unsubstantiated
i'm calling them a bunch by the way i
agree with you right i'm a big fan of
the queen so here's what so let me ask
you what you would have done then so
then it turns out meghan markle writes
to my boss
itv and basically demands my head on a
plate
and the next day i'm told i've either
got to apologize for disbelieving that
or or i had to lose my job now what
would you have done i would have left
but i wouldn't have attacked a
weatherman you know
he wasn't worth it i didn't attack him i
left the room well you did no you
attacked him uh he attacked you and then
i would have handled it differently but
that's okay you know would you have
apologized for what would you do
i've known you a long time would you
have apologized well i thought you were
right about the thing i just didn't like
the way you handled it is that okay i
think you're not wrong about i shouldn't
have walked off i don't know if you're
going to leave this on your interview
but we're going to leave on the
interview okay
i mean i don't want to insult you so
it's called piers morgan on sensitive
yeah you're allowed to have your opinion
part of what happened to me was this
issue of censorship and free speech
you've had uh
a taste of this by being removed from
twitter which was a great platform for
you you were very popular on it and you
were very entertaining on it depending
on your viewpoint yeah i liked you on it
i miss you on it it used to cheer up a
boring day and twitter is now boring
would you miss do you miss being on
twitter
so
i'm doing my own platform i think it's
going to be very big i think it's going
to be very successful we'll see
but we need a voice
the good news is i have a voice because
i do interviews with you and other
people some friends and some not friends
of yourself some you know very well
right and some you respect a lot and
some you don't yeah but i'm able to get
my voice out but twitter uh what they're
doing is really horrible if you've got
two things they did which i think are
really contentious one they've continued
to ban you from from the platform but
they allow vladimir putin to have a
twitter account they allow the supreme
leader of iran to have a twitter account
they allow a number of taliban leaders
to have a twitter account i don't see
how they can square off allowing those
people
to have their platform you know what i'm
not a former president united states do
you know why because they're sick
they're mentally ill i really believe
that they're sick people
and our country is going to hell right
now our country is going to hell
we have people we have an invasion at
the southern border and beyond but we
have an invasion coming in this this is
bigger than any army is coming in and
it's not 2 million people i believe it's
10 or 12 million people a year at the
end of biden's term i think you'll have
30 to 40 to 50 million people will have
come into our country
many of these people are not people that
would ever qualify for any country many
are people released from prisons from
other countries you know last week
last week we had 129 countries
representative it's no longer honduras
and guatemala and mexico and you know
the area
it's now it's
they think like oh they're coming in
from el salvador
it's now the whole world is being dumped
into the united states we're like a
garbage dump
and this is allowed to go on
and the media doesn't want to talk about
it if you turn on to
nbc fake news or cbs fake news any of
them cnn which is you know totally fake
if you turn onto they don't even talk
about the border they rarely talk about
the border such an important thing and
they rarely talk our country is being
invaded
and we do nothing about it i believe and
we'll finish up with this but i believe
our country has never been at a lower
point we had the strongest border in the
world we're the strongest border we've
ever had
and now we have the weakest border we
had the best economy and now we have
inflation that's destroying you know
inflation
if you're like in real estate like i am
and was
if you're in real estate inflation is a
wonderful thing until everything except
here's a big
one says the next trump's answer to a
simple question what is a woman and i'll
show you how our interview really is
turn the camera
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now what do you think the
the council culture woke debate is now
beginning to really damage the democrats
i'll give you the example that's been
raging recently this whole issue of
transgender athletes in sport for
example in women's sport leah thomas the
swimmer i think it's grotesquely unfair
it is you know you can support trans
rights to equality and fairness but also
understand that what's going on in sport
is inherently unfair and unjust and
unequal is is that your position people
see it and they won't put up with it
they had a weight lifter
where the record was for 11 or 12 years
and they'd put a half an ounce on each
side and the woman would lift a guy
comes along and breaks the record by
numbers that you wouldn't johnson came
out recently and said he would ban
biological males people born with
biological male bodies who transition he
would ban them from then competing in
women's sport good do you agree with
that i do i do i agreed with it long
before anybody else i think it's
ridiculous and it's uh sad and it's bad
for the democrats because they're not
going to do that
one of the big questions being put a lot
to politicians right now
is what is a woman
i'm not i'm not going to respond to the
question but a woman is a woman is
somebody that swims at a certain time
and doesn't get beaten by 38 seconds by
somebody that wasn't even a good swimmer
as a male
how could i not talk about exactly how
our incredible interview finally ended
after all it's made global headlines
because apparently the promo was rigged
donald trump himself issued two
statements branding it fake news well
here's what really happened
i was pleasantly surprised that you came
out and said that you've not only been
fully vaccinated but you thought other
people should well we saved tens of
millions of lives maybe this would have
been the spanish flu of 1917 had we not
come up and i got it done in nine months
as opposed to they were projecting from
five to 12 years i got it done in nine
months so i'm very proud of it you were
great i'm against mandates right
strongly against mandates but i'm very
proud of what we did i saved
worldwide tens of millions of lives one
last question do you accept that early
on in the pandemic
that you didn't take it seriously enough
or you were being told how serious it
was no i didn't accept i was sharing
that with the american people i'm a
cheerleader for this country
i want to be positive for this country i
take everything seriously and i took
that very seriously but i'm a
cheerleader for the country and our
country came out of it better than
anybody else we've done a great job a
final question president trump it's been
good to catch up with you after this uh
lengthy time i haven't mentioned it
that's it no yeah yeah last question no
i i realize that you're lying
i'm not like very different i just
haven't asked you you're a very dissent
this was a 20-minute interview
listen this was a 20-minute interview
uh i think it's fine it's fine it's i
have an awesome fantastic in your
opinion i wanted to end with the holy
one i just haven't asked about the holy
one do you want to go ahead
you recently
got a hole in one playing golf with
ernie else one of the great golfers of
the world what was that like for you
well it was great he's a great guy great
player one of the most beautiful swings
they say in the history of golf and very
powerful and i made it with him and
actually three other tour pros
and it was quite a thrill talk me
through the shot
well i hit the ball it was hit well it
felt good the wind was blowing hard into
my face it was a 5r that went 181 yards
and it went clank right into the hole it
landed on the green in one bounce and it
went clank and ernie who's a low-key guy
one of the reasons he's acceptable the
big easy right
but ernie and the other pros started
jumping up and down in the air and they
said why are you guys so excited he says
because we don't see hollow ones
they make i guess one every three
tournaments and then you have to be in
the group so it's really wonderful i've
had seven this was a seven seven holy
seven this was my seventh which isn't
that high in number believe it or not if
somebody plays golf
i hear the record is 49. okay people can
buy a round of drinks in the bar
afterwards i don't know but i would
certainly have been happy to if you
don't drink
i don't drink now at least traditionally
you buy around forever that is true that
is true did you do that probably
happened i didn't check but probably
happened because i owned the club i'm
sure it happened congratulations on the
holy one all right thank you very much
thank you very much thank you very
much it
okay thank you okay let's go that was a
great interview yeah that's fine thank
you very much i really appreciate it
turn the camera off
so there was the most explosive
interview of the year and that was the
first one we did on piers morgan
censored it's already triggered four
separate presidential statements of
theory from donald trump and yet as
things stand he still remains one of the
favorites to run again for office in
2024 and if he was to win again he'd be
the second person in history to become
president for a second time quite
extraordinary if that was to happen
whatever you're up to this weekend make
sure it's unsensitive
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years at fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that remained at one and
at half past two four to three after
nigel farage had already said he'd lost
it turned out he hadn't lost but it
turned out we were leaving the european
union so that was quite shocking
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams tory
mp chris pincher has been suspended by
the party after being accused of
drunkenly groping two men during a night
out the former deputy chief whip
resigned yesterday after an incident in
which he said he embarrassed himself and
other people covert infections have
surged by more than 30 percent in the
last week to almost 2.3 million it's
thought to be driven by two new
sub-variants of omicron and in scotland
one in 18 people are currently infected
but they're not thought to be any more
lethal than other types of covet and
british hopefuls cameron nori and
heather watson have reached the fourth
round at wimbledon for the first time
novak djokovic has also eased through to
the next stage as well that's all for
now we'll have more updates after the
talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you